I'm legally required by talkshow rules
to ask you if we will see the Hulk again
I do know that I did give Kevin Feige
the blockbuster award at the Hollywood
Film Awards the other day to a
smattering of applause and and he did
say hey do you think there's any more
story left here and I said I could
probably come up with a few story lines
and he said well maybe you should come
in and we'll have a talk oh you heard it
here there it is
Stephen Colbert
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie Happy
New Year I got a lot of requests from
you to do a video about the big Holt
news apparently Marvel got the rights
back to do a Hulk movie so I'll try to
explain what's going on but as you can
see Mark Ruffalo is now pitching new
Hulk movies to Kevin Feige that would
make a lot more sense if they finally
have all the rights to the Hulk back so
break everything down what's going on
behind the scenes in my top picks for
what that hope movie could be if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the Marvel videos we're doing
a new IMAX ticket giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best pick for a new Hulk
movie on the video so you guys may have
seen recently the last couple of days
there been a lot of news reports from
websites that Marvel may have just
gotten the rights to do a Hulk solo film
back from Universal it makes a lot more
sense that they would be planning new
Hulk movies if that were true the clip
of Mark Ruffalo talking about new movies
with Kevin Feige is actually from the
summer a couple months ago after
Avengers end game came out because
everyone was wondering what are they
gonna do with the Hulk now his arms in a
sling is that going to heal because of
his gamma powers where's he gonna show
up during Marvel phase 4 when I first
saw that clip immediately I just assumed
that he was talking about business as
usual in terms of what they were allowed
to do with the whole character that many
would probably show up during the Marvel
phase for she-hulk series in Avengers 5
but Avengers 5 isn't happening for a
couple years till Marvel phase 5 the
she-hulk series is happening in the next
couple of years in the big reason why
they haven't made a new hulk solo film
since the Edward Norton Marvel phase 1
Incredible Hulk film is because up to
this point Universal has held the rights
to distribute Hulk movies it's not like
it was with Fox the x-men Deadpool and
Fantastic Four characters Universal
never had the rights to make a whole
movie
they just controlled the distribution
rights but the problem is is that's
where the studio's make all their money
so look at this giant chart here of who
holds the rights to all the Marvel
characters this was updated right after
Disney bought Fox so that's why all the
Fox characters are inside the giant red
Marvel bubble notice some of the studios
like Sony where they share the rights
with characters it's the same with
Universal there's a sort of sharing
situation going on
Universal got the rights to the whole
characters back when Marvel went
bankrupt in the 90s and they had their
fire sale on the movie rights to all
their big characters that's when Sony
got the rights to spider-man when Fox
got the rights to x-men and Fantastic
Four I don't say Deadpool because
technically Deadpool falls under the
x-men rights even though he is a
franchise by himself has surpassed the
traditional x-men films but since the
90s Marvel has always had the rights to
physically make a Hulk solo film they
just haven't had the rights to
distribute it meaning that Marvel and
Disney wouldn't make any money on the
hope movies that they would make the
deal with the spider-man characters
isn't quite the same thing because
technically Sony makes most of the
box-office money and Marvel just gets
the rights to include spider-man in
their movies the brand-new sharing deal
that they just signed to get Tom Hall
and back into the MCU gives Marvel a
bigger piece of the box-office pie but
for the most part Sony distributes the
spider-man films Marvel just makes them
Sony makes most of the money on the
box-office Marvel makes most of the
money on the merchandise and all the
other stuff outside of the movie
apparently up to this point though
Universal was not willing to make the
same kind of deal with Marvel that Sony
did so there's that funny video of Mark
Ruffalo talking about Universal hating
money watch this this is actually from
before Avengers end game I want to just
make one thing perfectly clear today a
standalone Hulk movie will never happen
because Universal has the rights to the
standalone Hulk movie and for some
reason they don't know how to play well
with Marvel and they don't want to make
money and with you as the new Hulk it
would be terrible know that these
corporations would work it out if they
thought they'd make enough money so I
think about who's playing let's but I
mean I figure I got like two or three
more years left before they I'm too old
to play the whole we talked about it but
I just I don't see it in the cards he's
feeding the cards means a lot to me I
mean I really love this character
that clip is from a while ago you can
hear the bitterness in his voice like he
just never believes in his heart of
hearts that they're ever going to be
able to do a solo hulk film and based on
what he says it sounds like up to this
point Universal didn't want to make the
same type of deal with Marvel that Sony
did for the spider-man character but
apparently whatever black magic ritual
Marvel and Kevin Feige performed
recently they may have just fixed all
their hope problems with that and that's
why you're seeing these news reports
from websites saying that they can make
a new Hulk movie again it will be set
after the events of Avengers endgame so
you'd have the professor version of Hulk
you'd have to explain what happens to
him before you do anything else with the
character but here are my top picks for
what they can do with new Hulk stories
that they have not done yet just some
easy slam dunks first stop is just going
back to the planned story arc they
originally had for Edward Norton's
Incredible Hulk you may have seen the
article going around about Tim Blake
Nelson he was the actor that played the
leader during that movie and they just
disappeared because they didn't make any
more sequels he revealed the original
plans for that trilogy he said that
William Hurt Edward Norton and himself
all signed on to do a trilogy of
incredible hulk movies eventually his
leader character was supposed to become
the main villain you all saw what
happened because of the problems with
the rights and they got rid of Edward
Norton for Mark Ruffalo before the first
Avengers movie Marvel led Tim Blake
Nelson out of his contract and then
signed William Hurt to a new one so that
he could appear during civil war and all
the other Marvel films Edward Norton
also recently revealed why he was fired
by Marvel because he got into a big
creative fight with them and Kevin Feige
over the idea of what that whole trilogy
was going to become because Edward
Norton claims that he signed on for a
much darker hardcore version of the hope
than what we've seen from Mark Ruffalo's
version a hardcore version of the Hulk
would be amazing world war hulk would
even make a great Avengers movie forget
just sola hawk movies you could actually
turn that into a big Avengers crossover
then there is the classic Hulk vs.
Wolverine easy slam-dunk movie they're
not even gonna have space in their movie
release schedule to actually release a
new hulk solo movie til Marvel phase 5
and that's the target period when
they're introducing a lot of their new
x-men Marvel characters it would be
super easy for them to do hope vs.
Wolverine then and talk about deep cut
comic book origins comic book Wolverine
debut
for the first time in the Incredible
Hulk comics Hulk was rampaging his way
across the Canadian border so the
Canadian version of Thunderbolt Ross
unleashed quote-unquote Weapon X on him
when he steps out of the shadows to
fight the Hulk its Wolverine wearing his
original comic book costume over the
next several years they had several
rematch fights in the comics he
eventually got his own solo title then
Wolverine joined the x-men and so on and
so forth
the other really easy slam dunk is just
giving Thunderbolt Ross a proper Red
Hulk origin story and then passing the
Hulk torch to him so to speak in the
movies for a little while on route to a
Thunderbolts Red Hulk series or even a
Dark Avengers movie
I think Marvel and Sony do have big
plans for the Norman Osborn character
eventually a very different version of
his character but if they can't do that
Thunderbolt Ross would be a great proxy
for that he does show up prominently
during the Black Widow trailer but there
are two different versions of
Thunderbolt Ross in that trailer there's
the one that you see and then the one
you hear the voice over he has with
Natasha is actually from the events of
Captain America Civil War when she goes
on the run back to Budapest
the version you see here in this scene
who looks way younger with the D aging
technology seems like it's actually from
the 90s because he doesn't have any gray
hair this is all blonde and is probably
from the first time he meets Natasha
when she's still part of the Black Widow
program my early theory about what's
going on with Thunderbolt Ross right now
just based on the footage we've seen and
what they've talked about is I think
they're using him in a sort of reverse
Nick Fury type of role like they don't
want to put Nick Fury in this film even
though he is prominent in Natasha's
backstory but they want to use
Thunderbolt Ross in service of setting
up a Thunderbolts or Dark Avengers
future project with the Jelena Bulova
character taking the mantle of Black
Widow after the events of Avengers
endgame in having Thunderbolt Ross asked
her to join his quote unquote new team
that he's putting together Nick Fury
style
the really cool thing being that it
becomes a dark mirror for that original
Nick Fury Iron Man post-credits scene at
the beginning of phase 1 but let me know
in the comments if Marvel got the rights
back to do a whole solo film what kind
of movies do you want them to do with
him during Marvel phase 5 you may have
also seen they're finally releasing a
brand new New Mutants trailer tomorrow
morning that'll probably be my next
video so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
that when I posted every one click here
to learn about the new
quicksilver stuff that's happening with
dr. strange two-in-one division and
click here for my brand-new Marvel
Deadpool 3 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome happy
new year
[Music]
you